Susan Kim is the owner
of Elizabeth Albert,
a boutique that sells
some of the top women's
fashions on the Burbank strip.
But lately, she's noticed
that sales have taken a dip.
- People are buying less,
or they're really tightening
their belt.
- It could be because,
in a neighborhood
populated largely
by young couples,
Susan was forgetting
all about the men.
So I paid her a visit
with a way
to keep couples happy
in her store.
To be honest with you,
as a guy,
this store is pretty boring.
- 'Cause it's
a women's store.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- So, if I came in here
with my girlfriend,
hypothetically speaking--
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't have a--
have a girlfriend--
um, but...
you know, I think
I'd be nagging her to leave.
- 'Cause men
don't like to spend time
in a women's clothing store
anyway.
- Until now.
You see,
when a guy has nothing to do,
the woman he's with
feels a psychological pressure
to leave,
which will often keep her
from staying longer
and buying more stuff.
A dedicated Man Zone
where guys can chill and relax
while the women shop.
- That's--
sure, that makes sense.
- I mean, trust me,
I know guys.
All we need
is a beer in our hand
and a bro by our side,
and we are out of the way.
- I never--
I've, in fact, never heard
any guy saying that.
"If I had a brew
and a bro, I'm fine."
- I totally hear you,
but leave it to me
for the guy stuff.
Trust me.
- Okay.
- Susan was on board,
and we decided
that her back storage area
would be the perfect spot
for the new Man Zone.
So the next day,
I had my team bring in
all the essentials
to make this room
the ultimate hangout den
for guys.
And once everything
was in its place,
all we had to do was wait
for the first couple to come in
to see if my Man Zone
would work.
Just so you guys know,
Elizabeth Albert has
a dedicated Man Zone,
so that means
while the lady shops,
you have a place
you can hang out
that's both comfortable
and geared
towards your masculine needs.
[both laugh]
So, if you wanna
come hang out there
and let--
give her time to shop--
You want?
It's up to you.
- You do that, okay?
- Yeah.
- Don't leave this, uh,
bro hangin', dawg.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Great, and we'll be having fun
in there,
so take as much time
as you need.
- All right, thank you.
- Yeah, no problem.
I knew it wouldn't be
too much of a challenge
to lure guys into the Zone,
and once they saw it had
everything a guy could want,
I was hopeful
they wouldn't want to leave.
Free at last,
free at last, huh?
I mean,
do you feel free?
- Yeah.
- Things were off
to a good start.
The guy's girlfriend
was leisurely shopping,
while back in the Zone...
You know what I feel like?
A mother-effin' beer.
It was just boys being boys...
Nice catch.
Just two dudes doing
what guys do best...
Crack that shit.
Hanging out,
grabbing a brewski,
and watching
royalty-free football.
Oh, yeah.
Tampa Bay Bandits
versus Houston Gamblers.
Enjoy.
Big tackle coming.
There we go.
I thought
he was having a good time,
but then,
something bad happened.
- I'ma go.
I'ma head out.
- Okay.
The guy decided
to leave the Zone
and go back to his girlfriend
after only four minutes.
And even worse, moments later,
they left the shop entirely.
This was not
what I had promised Susan.
I worried that if I lost
another guy that quickly,
there would be
no winning her back.
So when the next couple
came in,
I had to somehow
figure out a way
to keep the guy
chilling for longer,
or else my Man Zone
didn't stand a chance.
- You know
what I feel like?
- Oh, yeah?
- A mother-effin' beer.
Oop. Sorry.
Just meant to do
a little move.
- Okay. Oh, cool.
- There you go, man.
- I appreciate it, bro.
- Enjoy.
So far, things were working out
with my second guy...
- That's not good.
- Gotta let it set.
As he was relaxed
and enjoying his beer.
But when I put on
football again,
for some reason,
this guy wasn't into it either.
Great touchdown celebration
coming up.
Love that celebration.
Just a few minutes in, I could
tell I was losing him quick.
And with his girlfriend
just starting to shop,
I desperately needed
to turn things around.
But that's when I realized
I hadn't yet bro'd down
about the one thing
that's on every guy's mind.
You know what I like
more than anything?
- What?
- Sex.
- Se--oh, yeah.
Hell yeah, man.
You can never get
too much sex, man.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Never too much sex, bro.
Oh, yeah.
- Definitely, definitely.
- Oh, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
- What's your favorite,
uh, posish?
- From the back.
- Hmm?
- From the back, yeah.
From behind, yeah.
- Oh, nice.
- Straight damage, bro.
- Mine's missionary.
- Missionary?
- Yeah.
- Guy on top,
girl on the bottom.
- There you go.
Nothing's wrong with that, man.
Nothing's wrong with that.
- The sex talk was working,
and the guy was loving
every minute of it.
Bareback or use a condom?
- Oh, bareback, man.
I love the feeling.
- Only way.
- All the way, bro.
- It feels much--so much better
without a condom,
you know what I mean?
- Aw, hell,
definitely, dude.
- It's like so much stuff
these days, it's like,
"Oh, you gotta use protection,"
all this stuff.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- But, like, whatever.
You pull out,
you're fine, right?
- Absolute--
as long as you pull out, man.
- As long as you pull out.
- That's the key.
- Gotta pull out.
- Have to pull out, bro.
You have to.
- Sometimes I get close.
You know what I mean?
- Oh, yeah, like, "Whoo!"
Almost got me right there!
- Sometimes I get real close!
[both laugh]
Yeah!
- Exactly, bro.
- Yeah.
I did it.
As long as we were talking
about sex,
this guy wasn't going anywhere,
and best of all,
his girlfriend
had time to browse
every section of the store
without interruption.
- From behind, that's--
that's pretty much--
I just like to see everything,
man, you know.
You can't--
can't go wrong with that.
- The guy stayed
in the Man Zone
for a full 17 minutes
before leaving,
and victory had never tasted
so sweet.
- Drinking a beer.
- Yeah!
- And even though women
may never really understand
what guys need...
- Why are you drinking beer?
- Well, that's what guys do
when they're alone.
- I don't care what they do
She left because he was
in there drinking beer.
- The only thing
that really mattered
is that Elizabeth Albert
now had a place
where guys
could be themselves.
- There have been times
in my life
when I was able to ejaculate
in another position,
but especially as I've gotten
older and fatter,
it's pretty much the only
position that works for me.
- That makes sense.